yeah they're coming out the prince is
holding the baby the royal family may
have changed beyond measure
since the births of Princes William and
Harry and so have the media who report
on them but so many of the traditions so
much of the protocol and all the theatre
of a royal birth has stayed the same the
first indication that a child has been
born will be when a member of the royal
household walks down this staircase
carrying an envelope it will contain a
notice of the birth but at this stage it
be sealed from the eyes of the world
it'll then travel by car and with a
police escort to Buckingham Palace where
the details will be revealed the car
will travel through the center of London
darkness with helicopters looking from
overhead as the world waits to find out
if the child is a prince or a princess
meanwhile at Buckingham Palace an easel
will be placed in the forecourt waiting
for the contents of the envelope it'll
be taken out of the car and framed
before being put on display by a footman
it may seem strange in the age of
Twitter but Buckingham Palace has chosen
to keep the tradition of the easel it
maintains a sense of occasion about the
birth it's the same one that was used to
announce the arrival of Prince William
and it's the way the world is going to
discover whether the latest member of
the royal family is male or female as
news of the baby's arrival spreads the
story of the future king or queen begins
but his or her birth will be heralded in
much the same way as the last royal
generation